Dr. Zakia, next question is a very
common question and it's one that I'd
like to know the answer to as well. It's
um if all the devils are chained during
the month of Ramadan, how come people
continue to commit sins?
And I do agree with you. This is a
common question. And I remember several
years back when I was in school and when
I heard this hadith that the devils are
chaining the month of Ramadan
immediately the question that came to my
mind and the question that comes to many
Muslims mind and many non-Muslims is
that if the devils are chained then how
do people how do human beings yet commit
sins.
This question is based on the hadith of
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
which I mentioned earlier a say had of
Musnad Ahmed
volume number two page number 230 had
number 7,148
which is also repeated in
sunai chapter number five had number
where the beloved prophet said
that Oi people, the blessed month of
Ramadan is approaching and Allah has
ordained for you that you fast in this
month
and
the gates of heaven will be open in this
month and the gates of hell will be
closed and the devils will be chained
in this month is a night which is better
than a thousand months and a person
who's deprived of the blessing in this
is truly a deprived person. Now when we
give this hadith it clearly mentions
that in this month of Ramadan the devils
will be chained and it's a logical
question if devils are chained then how
do human beings yet commit sins
to make the people understand
we have to realize that when the devils
are chained it does not mean that the
devils are slain they have been killed
they yet present but they are chained
They're not killed. The power is yet
there but it is diminished. For a better
understanding, I'd like to give you an
example that when there is a lion or a
tiger who is free, there are high
chances that he may kill you. Your life
is in danger. But the moment that tiger
or that lion is chained, you are safe.
You are safe as long as you maintain a
safe distance.
After the tiger has been chained, if you
come too close to him, there are chances
yet you can be killed. So as long as you
maintain that distance from the tiger
who is chained, you are safe. Similarly,
in the month of Ramadan, if you maintain
a safe distance from the Satan, you'll
be saved. And if you read the Quran,
Allah says in surah bakar chapter 2
verse number 168, be careful of thewatan
of the footsteps of the devil for he is
to you an avowout enemy. Many places
Allah subhananaa tala says in the Quran
that be careful of the footsteps of the
devil. Allah doesn't say that be careful
of the devil because a normal Muslim an
average Muslim who has average iman when
he sees the devil in front of him he
will be careful for example
suppose there's a young girl who comes
to an average Muslim a young boy who has
average iman if a young girl comes and
tells him that let's spend the night
together that Muslim will say spending
the night together with the girl it's
haram it is zena he will immediately
object but that same girl if that girl
phones that young boy and speaks to him
on the phone the boy will say speaking
to a girl on the phone there's no
problem so he speaks to the girl for a
few times on the phone for a few minutes
later on the girl says let's go and have
some snacks in McDonald's on Kentucky
Fried Chicken having snacks
for a few minutes, for half an hour with
a girl in McDonald's. No problem. So he
goes and has snacks with the girl in
McDonald's. Later on the girl says, why
not have dinner in a restaurant? Having
dinner with a girl in restaurant for a
couple of fast? No problem. Then the
girl says, why not spend the night
together? And then the boy says,
spending the night together with a girl,
no problem. So this is
footsteps of the devil. This is not
mentioned in the Quran. This is just my
own example. So what Allah warns us is
that be careful of the
the footsteps of the devil. If the devil
comes directly in front of an average
Muslim who has iman, he will abstain. He
will run away from it. But theatan are
the things which are dangerous.
So what we have to realize when the
devil is chained
his footsteps are restricted.
So many of the sins are prevented. But
if we go close to him
then the chances that we'll be overtaken
by the devil and commit a sin are very
high. So what we have to be careful that
in Ramadan if we keep the distance then
the chance of committing sin is less.
But if we go close to the Satan even
though he's chained like how a tiger can
walk even after he's chained. Same the
devil. So this is my understanding. And
the beloved prophet said the devils are
chained the devil cannot move but less
distance. So if we keep the distance
we'll be safe. The second reason that I
feel is that in the month of Ramadan
though the devils are chained we fail to
realize that the balance 11 months they
are free and the impact that the devil
has on the human beings for these 11
months it leaves those impact that
impression in the month of Ramadan to
give a better understanding I always
give the example that there are drug
peddlers
which try and get customers the
youngsters from the colleges from the
universities. So what they do initially
they give the drug free and they entice
the youngsters for having drugs later on
after some time they charge a nominal
amount for that drug. Later on they
charge an exorbitant amount but by the
time the youngster is already hooked
onto the drug.
So even if the drug dealer is not there
they will try and find where the drug
dealer is they will go out of the way to
find him and get the drug. And many of
them even if the drug peddler the drug
dealer is imprisoned by the law they
will go out of the way to find someone
else. They may go in a chemist shop and
buy man bricks whatever it is they are
so much hooked on to it. So these people
who have become addicts
to drugs or rather say addicted to the
Satan even though the Satan is
imprisoned the effect is yet there. So
in this way we understand as a drug
dealer as a drug peddler even after he
goes the drug addict gets accustomed to
that drug. So we human beings we are
accustomed to the sin and even though
the Satan is imprisoned we keep on
committing this mistakes but mainly
those people who have become addicts
fall in this category. So those who do
major sin fall in this category but the
normal Muslims the average Muslims who
haven't become addicted it's easy for
them to stay away from sin.
And the third reason that I give
is
that though there are some scholars who
say that in this month of Ramadan the
strong
devils the mars they imprisoned the
smaller ones are afraid so they keep on
committing mistakes but
my understanding
the third reason is
that
though the devils are chained by Allah
subhana wa ta'ala they can yet whisper
and one of the ways the devils try and
get the human beings close to them is by
whispering
and Allah says in the Quran in surah nas
chapter number 114 verse number 1-6
They whisper in the hearts of the human
beings and they withdraw. Amongst them
the jin and men. It's talking about the
Satanist talking about the devils who
whisper into the hearts of the human
being and they withdraw. And among these
devils are the jin and the human beings.
So maybe Allah subhanana wa ta'ala has
imprisoned the devils who are the jin
but the human beings we are yet free. So
one category of devils that the gins
have been imprisoned but the satans are
even amongst the men that's what Allah
says
who are yet free and yet we have to be
careful of the whisper of the devil the
basa this basa mainly is the thing that
attracts toward the sin the sins they
had committed but the chances are less
and furthermore it's clearly mentioned
in the full hadith that Allah has
ordained for you in this month of
Ramadan that you should fast.
Only if you fast according to me will
the devils be imprisoned. That's talking
about the devils that are going to
attract you. So Allah says if you fast
Allah has ordained for you fasting and
the devils will be put in chains. So the
devils that are after you if you fast
surely they'll be restricted. The
criteria for us to be away from the
devil is to fast. If you fast with the
proper nia
seeking the reward of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala, surely the devil will not be
able to entice you. And the best logical
way to prove this is if we check the
crime rate of
the Muslim countries during Ramadan, it
goes down. But if you check the crime
rate of the non-Muslim countries in
Ramadan, it is the same. The reason is
that because they are not fasting the
non-Muslims,
this devil yet has an effect on them
because the Muslims are fasting
if not all properly at least majority or
at least quite a large number. So
because of that the crime rate in the
Muslim country within the month of
Ramadan is low as compared to the other
months. But the crime rate in the
non-Muslim country is approximately the
same indicating otherwise even the
non-Muslims they will not commit any
sins. So the criteria is that you have
to fast properly for the sake of Allah
subhana wa tala.